لا تزال الولايات المتحدة هي
المستهلك الأول للمياه المعبأة في العالم، لماذا لا تزال
زجاجات المياه البلاستيكية تحظى
بشعبية كبيرة في الولايات المتحدة عندما
تكون الخسائر البيئية معروفة جيدًا،
نعم بالنسبة لبعض الناس، فهي ترف أو
راحة للآخرين، إنها ضرورة
تعرفها عندما نكون  لقد رأينا أشياءً في فلينت
أو جاكسون ميسيسيبي
أو حتى الرمال في فرع تكساس، ولكن ما
فشلنا في إدراكه في بعض الأحيان هو أن
كل قطعة من البلاستيك
تم تصنيعها بشكل ما أو
بطريقة ما لا تزال موجودة وتتسبب في
مشاكل تتعلق بصحة الناس والحياة
البرية.  ولعب دور أيضًا في
ما يحدث مع أزمة المناخ،
لذلك يتعين علينا التركيز حقًا في
هذه اللحظة للبدء في شفاء المجتمعات والحياة
البرية وكوكبنا، لذا فقد
تطرقت إلى هذا الأمر نوعًا ما ولكن أعتقد أن الناس قد
يعتقدون أن المياه المعبأة في زجاجات  أليس هذا سيئًا
لأنهم يعتقدون أن الزجاجة يتم
إعادة تدويرها، هل يمكنك أن تعطينا
فحصًا واقعيًا لإعادة التدوير،
نعم هناك تقدير أنه يتم بالفعل إعادة تدوير ما
بين تسعة إلى اثني عشر بالمائة من
الزجاجات،
ونحن نعلم أن الشركات الست الكبرى
التي تقوم بالتصنيع
الموجودون في هذا الفضاء يقومون فقط
بنسبة صغيرة مما يمكن أن
يفعلوه ولماذا يعد هذا
مهمًا لأننا نعلم أن هناك
ترشيحًا يحدث من زجاجات المياه هذه
والتي يمكن أن تسبب عددًا من
الأشياء التي تؤثر على كليتيك
كبدك وأيضًا هناك بعض أنواع
السرطان المرتبطة أيضًا، لذا
لدينا الكثير من الأسباب التي تجعلنا بحاجة إلى القيام
بذلك وعلينا أن نتحرك الآن